oh no
so i just did sour cream and sour cream
you guys chose this
hey guys it's katie and jasmine and
welcome to lost in translation thanks to
your love and support we are now
officially a series
so we'll have a new episode every week
for the next four weeks make sure you're
subscribed and your notification bell is
turned on if this is your first time
here what we do is we take a recipe we
put it through google translate it goes
from english to indonesian to past show
to basque and many many many more until
finally back to english to give us a
really hilariously translated recipe
i've gotten to torture my friends katie
kelly and nemo which was so much fun but
now you are back in the hot seat and we
got a recipe from you guys so let's go
get in there okay okay i don't know how
much you're gonna love them after you
get the recipe
[Music]
are you ready i'm ready here we go
where's mimo oh evo's on vacation lauren
is here doing sound she might give me
some clues but just because she's not
here doesn't mean you guys won't see her
i really did a number on her didn't i
are you ready to do this always
a candy box i love candy oh yeah i'm so
excited let's get into it step one bring
it to josh
break the three fruit reduce heat to
medium and cook for 12 minutes josh josh
josh josh bring it to josh who could
josh possibly
be
heat up your pan bring water up to boil
because the end of that sentence is
reduce heat to medium and cook for
12 minutes josh wants boiling hot water
that's what josh is gonna get lemons
boil three lemons
i'd like to use a hit
really just to get us on the right track
who would you like your hint from katie
oh my god i got picked first the three
things you break or something you often
eat for breakfast
i might have done lemons so i'm happy i
use the hint have you boiled lemons
that's what's insane you never know
what's happening when you're up here
anything goes okay we're gonna do three
eggs in my massive pot we're gonna leave
this for 12 minutes and then we'll move
on to step two all right step number two
oily ice rubs against the skin and it's
easy i think oily ice is putting the
eggs in an ice bath and then the skin is
the shell and with the ice it's like
and then it's easier to crack i'm gonna
take the eggs out
time to crack our eggs take it out and
then we're gonna peel it i've done this
before i feel like this really does help
heal the eggs better so do you think
this bath helped um
it's not easy i'll be back before we
move on to step three step number three
make a quilt bed in bowl combine three
dried berries one tablespoon of fried
beef
one teaspoon of lemon juice quarter cup
mayonnaise salt and pineapple in bowl i
can do that i can do bowls dried berries
dried berries dried berries dried
berries
my eggs are my dried berries
you guys chose this
i'm about to cry because of josh what is
fried beef chopped parsley actually beef
bouillon
okay i changed my mind i'm gonna do a
tablespoon of beef
bouillon where'd i put it oh curious i'm
going to do one tablespoon i use
bouillon all the time in my soups and my
stocks and stuff do you ever put it in
not soups and stalks
oh no one teaspoon lemon juice i think
lemon lemon zest all right all aboard
quarter cup mayonnaise i'm gonna trust
this one i don't really trust people who
don't like mayo i don't love mayo
salt and pineapple salt and pepper
i'll just do like a dash and then some
black pepper make a mixture i guess i
will combine all of this step number
four cut 12 pieces of white paper with a
sharp knife cut cut cut cut we're
cutting we're done
i think cut 12 pieces of white paper
white paper white bread white bread
brioche there's a baguette perhaps we
should do this
there's not enough mixture for 12 pieces
of bread so i am lost
in translation
all right i am gonna cut the bread into
12 slices i can't even grip this
properly it makes me feel like i'm doing
something wrong i'm gonna cut this into
12 slices i'll be right back
okay my bread is sliced let's move on to
step five in a small bowl combine one
cup cream fries and two cup cheese until
they get along well
oh no there's cream cheese
sour cream
creme fraiche i kind of want to say sour
cream
one cup cream fries is one cup sour
cream two cups cheese is two cups creme
fraiche
she's staring at me
don't give in one cup of cream fries i'm
going with one cup sour cream have you
ever cooked with crumb fresh before um
once i was making a sweet dessert gonna
combine all of this tastes like sour
cream it is
wait actually yeah creme fraiche is like
it has more fat and it's like a thicker
sour cream so i just did sour cream and
sour cream
[Laughter]
now i'm gonna mix this until they get
along looks like they get along great
because they're the same
step six to make the fish
bring the eight finished
fish
into a small bowl
fish oh my god smoked salmon
smoked trout
wild mackerel eight finished fish i
think is eight
slices of smoked salmon
step number seven add more
half cup sour cream two tablespoons an
onion three tablespoons lemon juice and
old chili powder
wash and dry
ugh it was cream cheese
i think add more half cup sour cream is
to take half cup from here and put it
over my smoked salmon for two
tablespoons of onion i'm gonna do
two tablespoons of onion powder three
tablespoons
lemon juice gotta make the lemons juicy
roll them out first i'm gonna just
eyeball three tablespoons old chili
powder i think is cayenne so i'm just
gonna add how much i like i think wash
and dry is like mix and stir am i
confident right now
absolutely
not this looks yummy at least it looks
delicious step number eight flour butter
place four loaves on the table flour
butter butter bread butter your bread
place four loaves on the table four
loaves one two three four flour is bread
butter the bread i like to butter my
buns
let's just go with unsalted because you
can always salt it i feel like i should
have toasted the bread let's move on to
step nine sprinkle a third of the cream
on the cream over the bread crumbs and
sprinkle with chopped grapes sprinkle a
third of the cream which cream let's do
this i'm gonna go with the cream on the
cream some cream on the cream on my
bread crumbs just an even layer sprinkle
with chopped grapes i feel like grapes
could not possibly mean grapes i feel
like the only similar thing i have right
now are these radishes
rad eye is that the plural for radishes
absolutely
so i think that chopped grapes is sliced
radishes my rad eye are sliced now let's
sprinkle them onto our loaves let's move
on to step ten spoon the onion into the
cream cheese layer
and spread evenly lay four layers of
bread on top
step 10 i think this calls for a hint oh
who would you like your hand from you
kelly or lauren lauren let's see how how
quality are your hints this onion lives
in the water
i guess she means fish
and i do have my fish mixture here i am
going to take my onion mixture which is
my fish mixture here and i guess i'll
cover my beautiful works of art four
layers of bread on top means just
one on each
one am i making little sandwiches
step 11 pour the next layer over the
cream cheese mask mask and fold in the
onions more onions
i think repeat i'm doing it i'm just
doing another layer of my sour cream
i'm currently wondering how one could
fit this into their mouth
fold in the onions chives i forgot about
chives i love chives so we should use
that on top or in here probably on the
bread tub finally brush the fruit salad
with the cream cheese and pour four
slices of pan on top
then the cream cheese okay so what i
think this means is add now the egg
salad over the cream cheese and then one
more layer of bread so now i have to
take my bread and put it on top maybe i
should have went with the other bread
step 13 cake
cut slices of ham
to three inches long they're already
three inches long make a flower by
rolling and stainlessing one of the ends
you have one clue left don't forget
dearest kelly may i use my final hint
these flowers are from the sea
this onion lives in the water
i'll make smoked salmon roses i've done
this with prosciutto before and i've
done it with avocados beautiful pretty
stainless means roll it from one end to
the other
my salmon roses are done they look so
cute step 14 the cake is baked with long
strings of carrots microwave
fried fish
dill and various onion ribbons i think
that the cake is baked means cake is
served so first i am going to plate my
candy boxes long strings of carrots you
know what i'll do chives but then i feel
like the roses should go on first so i'm
gonna put the roses on long strings of
carrots that's probably correct okay
what's next
microwave is micro greens i think my
fried fish is my
salmon rose dill i actually think it
might be dill okay a little piece of
dill and various onion ribbons i would
have guessed chives but because i
already did one long thing of chives i
will just skip that final step step 15
serve in pieces have fun
sure did candy box how do you feel you
know i i definitely have feelings let me
go grab ah do you think the audience is
going to be let down because of how
accurate i got it yeah i think they're
gonna be like wow
she's so good
open your eyes
[Laughter]
i mean beautiful
this cake is a swedish sandwich cake
also known as a smorgas torta i mean
it's beautiful i think i obviously did a
different version i'm gonna try mine
first
tastes like brunch filled with flavor
very umami a little too tall all right
i'm gonna try smorgast torta now the
layers are kinda what i did cheers
mmm that's pretty good the cream cheese
really helps balance everything out this
one good should we try it if you so dare
honestly this one tastes like a bagel
salty
why am i going for another bite katie
loves it this is a win this was a lot of
fun thank you so much for your
suggestion and make sure to tune in next
week bye
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like a hockey
someone please drop what you think josh
looks like so we can put him on a
t-shirt shout out to all the josh's
watching
i feel like josh is just a big egg
for the next four weeks we will have an
episode every week coming up in the next
four weeks and everyone how many of us
are watching
every week
you